hey i'm alex and today i'm going to show
you how to make my cookies and ice cream
dome cake
[Music]
so this recipe i came up with based on
two things one i wanted to make some
sort of a dome and two i wanted to use
oreos on the outside to make a really
cool visual so i knew this recipe would
naturally be cookies and cream flavored
because i was using the oreos but i
wasn't quite sure which
middle of the thing
i wanted to do could you done a
cheesecake i could have done an ice
cream cake but i decided to go with ice
cream cake because it was kind of new
and also i just really love cookies and
cream ice cream cake that's my favorite
kind of cake it's what i have on my
birthday usually fun fact
so i melted down the cream center in
order to put it back into the ice cream
base that we're gonna make which i might
add is my favorite part of the oreo
fun fact another fun fact this video is
full of fun facts
so the base is made out of more like a
whipped cream and a sweetened connects
milk and it still freezes up and holds
up like an ice cream would but just a
little lighter i would say less like
creamy than an ice cream would be
[Music]
the crushed up cookies will go in there
also
when you're whipping the cream you want
to make sure you get it to the point
where it's thick but don't whip it too
much because then it'll separate so
based on the size of your bowl it might
vary how many cookies you put in the
actual bowl itself but don't worry just
put them in until they line the full
bowl now some people might want to line
their bowl with plastic wrap in order to
get the dome cake out easier but you
actually don't need it it will pop out
on its own the tricky part about this
recipe was when i was testing it
sometimes the cookies would float up and
not stay in place so the batter had to
be thick enough to be able to hold the
cookies down then once you make your ice
cream face you'll dump that right on top
of the cookies and spread it evenly to
cover all the cookies this isn't like a
traditional ice cream this is more like
a frozen mousse kind of thing but it's
super delicious and then super easy just
pop it in the freezer and wait until
it's done you don't want to pull this
out early because you will have a big
mess
and also you just really want to make
sure it's frozen solid so you'll be able
to pop it out of the bowl easily just
flip it over on some sort of a board and
wait until it kind of loosens up and it
should fall right out and then you'll
have this beautiful oreo lined ice cream
cake the most important part of this was
making sure i nailed that beautiful
outside uniform layer and
to say it looked pretty cool
also what's nice is that the cookies
kind of soften up because of the ice
cream so you'll be able to cut into this
pretty easily
i think this recipe is great for like a
kid's birthday party because
what kid doesn't like ice cream cake and
also it's so fun looking make it for
your birthday party whether you're three
or 96 i'm sure you'll still love it this
is once you dome you don't go home 2.0
[Music]
you